what we're going to do in this video is
use the online graphing calculator
desmos and explore the relationship
between vertical and horizontal
asymptotes and think about how they
relate to what we know about limits
so let's first graph 2 over x minus 1.
so let me get that one graphed
and so you can immediately see that
something interesting happens at x is
equal to 1. if you were to just
substitute x equals 1 into this
expression you're going to get two over
zero and whenever you've got a non-zero
thing over zero that's a good sign that
you might be dealing with with a
vertical asymptote in fact we can draw
that vertical asymptote right over here
at x equals 1.
but let's think about how that relates
to limits what if we were to explore the
limit as x approaches 1 of f of x is
equal to 2 over x minus 1 and we can
think about it from the left and from
the right so if we approach 1 from the
left let me zoom in a little bit over
here
so we can see as we approach from the
left when x is equal to 0 the f of x
would equal to na would be equal to
negative 2 when x is equal to 0.5 f of x
is equal to negative 4 and then it just
gets more and more negative the closer
we get to 1 from the left i could really
so i'm not even that close yet if i get
to let's say
0.91
i'm still 900 less than 1 i'm at
negative 22.222
already
and so the limit as we approach 1 from
the left is unbounded some people would
say it goes to negative infinity but
it's really an undefined limit it is
unbounded in the negative direction and
likewise as we approach from the right
we get unbounded toward in the positive
infinity direction and and technically
we would say that that limit does not
exist
and this would be the case when we're
dealing with a vertical asymptote like
we see over here
now let's compare that to a horizontal
asymptote where it turns out that the
limit actually can exist
so let me delete these or just erase
them for now
and so let's look at this function which
is a pretty neat function i made it up
right before this video started but it's
it's kind of cool looking
but let's think about the behavior as x
approaches infinity so as x approaches
infinity it looks like our y value or
the value of the expression if we said y
is equal to that expression it looks
like it's getting closer and closer and
closer to 3. and so we could say that we
have a horizontal asymptote at y is
equal to 3 and we could also and there's
a more rigorous way of defining it
saying that say that our limit as x
approaches infinity is equal of the
expression or of the function
is equal to three notice my mouse is
covering a little bit as we get larger
and larger we're getting closer and
closer to three in fact it's we're
getting so close now that well here you
can see it we're getting closer and
closer and closer to 3.
and you could also think about what
happens as x approaches negative
infinity and here you're getting closer
and closer and closer to 3 from below
now one thing that's interesting about
horizontal asymptotes is you might see
that the function actually can cross a
horizontal asymptote it's crossing this
horizontal asymptote and this area in
between and even as we approach infinity
or negative infinity you can oscillate
around that horizontal asymptote let me
set this up let me multiply this times
sine
of x
and so there you have it we are now
oscillating around the horizontal
asymptote once again this limit can
exist even though we keep crossing the
horizontal asymptote we're getting
closer and closer and closer to it the
larger x gets and that's actually a key
difference between a horizontal and a
vertical asymptote vertical asymptotes
if you're dealing with a function you're
not going to cross it while with a
horizontal asymptote you could and you
are just getting closer and closer and
closer to it as x gets goes to positive
infinity or as x goes to negative
infinity